bonjour c'est michel denisot pour brut
malaman modèle monsieur bon toi la
première fois que j'ai fait un journal
télévisé c'était en régionale à limoges
way et c'était par accident je
remplaçais quelqu'un d'humble et et qui
avait un rendez vous galant
la direction n'était pas là et m'a dit
ce que tu peux m'en place et donc
j'étais à la radio à l'époque il est
évidemment que peut être remplacé m puis
on s'est fait engueuler le lendemain
mais j'ai continué j'ai pas eu le temps
de penser vraiment pas ce que j'ai je me
souviens que j'avais dans le tiroir je
présentais sûr c'est un bureau
présentera les classiques et j'avais mis
un verre de marée avec des martinis dans
le tiroir que entre les sujets je buvais
un coup à chaque fois pour justement pas
penser à autre chose que ce que j'avais
à faire
j'ai jamais rêvé de ce qui m'est arrivé
c'est après coup il me suis rendu compte
que ça aurait pu être un réveil de temps
en temps a pas toujours mais oui c'est
déjà eu envie d'être journaliste tout
simplement
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et dont 15 me
spécial que je vous présenterai avec
philippe gildas et marie sont venus
manger ce soir je pense qu'on sera pas
trop de trois
si aucun d'entre nous ne peut parler on
n'a aucune chance de continuer donc
coluche est mort alors je vous propose
de revoir le coluche qui était donc à
zurich lundi dernier ah oui c'est
compliqué ça on a un métier on doit
normalement dans la transmission de
l'information pas montré de sentiments
c'est normal mais parfois honte pas et
donc là c'était possible mais compliqué
je pouvais pas possible et je n'ai le
soir à mougins dans sa maison à l'époque
juste avant sa mort que où il a ou de
préparer son son nouveau spectacle
ces nouveaux ces nouveaux sketches qui
me faisait écouter et il me demandait
mon avis voilà et puis voilà donc ce
n'était pas rien moi je suis fan de
prince comme beaucoup de gens mais
j'avais la chance de pouvoir assister
aux répétitions l'après midi et les
répétitions étaient aussi forte que le
show parce qu'il répétait il n'arrivait
pas comme d'autres artistes une heure
avant pour faire la balance il répétait
tout l'après midi il arrivait à 12h 14h
pour 19h est il réglé tout est joué et
répèterai tout le monde le hobby c'est
ici il savait faire tout ce que les
autres devaient faire autour de lui donc
tout le monde le savait c'était un
patron la guitare on avait l'impression
c'était le prolongement de son bras
enfin tout était dalle turrel c'était un
voilà donc c'était effectivement du
travail au départ mais à l'arrivée c'est
tout semblait facile et très beau de
tous les gens que j'ai rencontrés c'est
celui qui m'a impressionné le plus il y
en a quelques-uns qui m'ont impressionné
mais finalement sans notre but c'est pas
être impressionné c'est notre métier
aussi de pas être impressionnée faux
dans pau faut parfois faire un effort
pour être impressionné de rester dans
notre rôle mais ils prennent c'était
compliqué quand je le voyais dans la
loge franchement il est dégagé pas grand
chose le particulier nommé il était
presque commun et dès qu'ils rentraient
sur scène c'est ne fallait rien à voir
et il était transféré il était
transformer quoi c'était quelques
c'était autre chose c'est comme s'il
descendait du ciel mais parti un peu à
la pêche pour faire une interview de lui
et elle sortait de prison depuis
quelques temps il allait revenir sur le
ring
on avait rendez vous à new york on est
arrivé n'était pas là on t'a dit l'état
phoenix on est parti à phoenix et puis
on a attendu 24 heures et il
s'entraînait dans une si vous voulez
retrouver un peu l'origine de la boxe
dans une salle assez vétustes la
température était monté à fond le du rap
à fond il s'entraînait comme on peut
l'imaginer puis je l'attendais au bord
du ring pour faire l'interview quand il
m'a serré la main j'ai un peu compté mes
doigts et c'était un moment assez fort
quoi et je me c'est toujours quand on
rencontre des gens qui sont à l'extrême
ce soit à l'extrême de certaines formes
de violence mais qui s'exprime sur le
ring avec lui mais où de la spiritualité
avec le dalaï lama que j'ai vu plus tard
que notre forme d'extrême gauche
parfois on ressent comme s'il y avait
une onde qui vous qui vous qui vous
frôlent est et c'est donc ça ça ne se
voit pas la télévision mais c'est ce
qu'on ressent ou les élections
présidentielles la campagne de 2007
la campagne commence ségolène royal va y
aller mais elle n'a pas dit qu'on a
réuni trois choses qui sont difficiles à
faire cohabiter et qui ont apporté
quelque chose
dire que diam's était dans une période
de succès avec la boulette etc
elle chante ça crée une atmosphère que
jamel récupère et arrive à faire le se
lever ségolène royal pour faire 2-2 pas
dedans si on peut appeler ça de la danse
et derrière il lui fait dire qu'elle est
candidate alors qu'elle avait prévu de
dire vous vous présenter aux élections
présidentielles ou pas parce que l'on
sait pas
c'est au mois de septembre qu'on va
décider nous l'aurions entre nous il ya
qu'il a personne tu regardes si ça reste
comme ça probablement oui à la du oui
c'est un concours de circonstances mais
ça n'arrive pas par hasard quoi quand ça
arrive ces choses là ça c'est un côté
hasardeuse mais c'est pas un hasard non
plus etc je trouve cela plus émouvant
que d'être fier ça m'émeut encore
aujourd'hui